inbound to Smart bounce pass Tatum Tatum
puts up a three Bang
s obtaining from downtown 1.3 remaining
no timeouts left for Philadelphia
oh no they say no good
came after the buzzer and the Celtics
win a thriller
they'll have to check it
and B
we will review this last second shot as
per rule the really on the floor was no
basket
absolutely still in his hands
replace it or confirms your own for a
decision
it's official
what a road victory for the Boston
Celtics they hold on and stop the 76ers
five game winning streak
what a game tonight here in Philadelphia
and the Celtics have run that play time
and again to get a running start for
Tatum inbounding to Smart who drops it
off to Tatum
excellent execution late
[Applause]
[Music]
what a pass from smart
and what a difference not having a
timeout
the building just those Bedlam but again
what a play you got to have a guy that
can get open he has the opportunity to
go either way use that size and strength
gets downhill gets to his spot and makes
the biggest play of the night and
another night you guys talked about it
where he didn't shoot the ball well but
still had a chance to win the game much
like he did in Indianapolis on Thursday
as the Boston Celtics now 20 and 10 on
the road this season the best road team
in the NBA with a magnificent Road win I
have never seen that where a guy gets
one erased on a full court shot late
let's check in with Lisa thank you Mike
Jason describe that ending for us I told
my teammates I told Graham coming out
that time out game time uh terrible game
but way to figure it out
describe the play what was the play that
Joe Missoula Drew up with you know smart
catch it you know me coming down hill go
ahead of steam make a play
a tough okay offensive night for you
just what was what were you thinking
before before you even got the ball find
a way to win the game I wasn't playing
my best I was just trying to impact
winning on both ends find a way
you guys
been down 15 in the third quarter until
Al Horford caught fire just described
the impact that he had on the game man
it's a hell of a team win right you know
nobody JB was playing well the whole
night but you know these guys just
making plays uh you know our death that
speaks our depth of our team and what we
trying to accomplish when the ball left
nb10 did you think it
I didn't even want to see it and you
know it's the NBA where amazing happened
so uh I'm glad it didn't count what is a
win like this mean for your team say
about your team wasn't your best night
you got it when you needed it what is it
a win like this say about this team it's
tough to win in this league
I'm sorry I'm sorry uh it's tough to win
it's tough to win in this league
um it showed the night with our
resilience and just wait to figure it
out congratulations on the win Jason
thank you appreciate it well the amazing
growth of Tatum continues what the wind
means is they stay ahead of Milwaukee
for the best record in the NBA and top
spot in the East they also win the
season series against Philadelphia now
3-0 against the Sixers with one more
game to go and they continue what has
been another magical regular season Now
44 and 17 overall 20 and 10 on the road
and a crushing defeat from Philadelphia
as they had a chance to pull off what
would have been a spectacular win but
just came up short in a great battle
between these two can't underestimate
that pass from smart that's a difficult
pass incredible thread the needle type
of pass and good defense just better
offense
well more NBA action tomorrow